she made me feel sorry for Serena Jewish
me and which is seemingly and impossible
to have I felt bad for her
[Music]
[Music]
the element that was missing for me was
the direct competition between the two
women with an older serena joyce or she
wants something so badly that she felt
like she should have had in the past but
she she passed that point now she's
older and she's using this young woman
to try to get that i felt that it was a
more active dynamic if Sarina Joyce I
like this person was used surfing for
role not only as the reproductive object
in the house but gradually taking away
the wifely duties the the intimate
romantic sexual duties something I
didn't expect happens is that Yvonne and
Elizabeth are close and and you get that
little vibe once in a while that in
another situation they could be friends
and it is the creepiest thing
[Music]
she's quite tall that works really well
with more small she said I think I'm
going to try something on the first Cape
Avon just got right down in her face and
it's terrified it's such a great moment
you will stay here and you will not
leave this room do you understand oh
you're like your dad may God bless our
cameraman if you see the shot it does
not shake when she comes in she dies at
you like a linebacker that's kind of a
vibrancy that you get from having a
younger more just the physical
intimidation Algrim if the advise is no
strong and she's kind of ripped strong
woman and Lizzie is also you know quite
strong and so the two of them together
you really get that nice like you feel
like I'd love to see them go toe-to-toe
you know in a cage format
you